[Music]
all right let's talk about this Sunday
the biggest names in country music will
get together for the Academy of Country
Music Awards and that's not the only
reason it's going to be one big wild
giant party the chill is also being
posted by Luke Bryan and Dierks Bentley
they are ready to roll it's my time in
the Sun and I mean this guy the epic is
that what the kids are saying these days
it's gonna be lit yes Luke lit is
correct the seat cards are set up and
get ready for some awesome super star
collaboration
[Music]
just try not to dance when Keith Urban
and Carrie Underwood sing the fighter
you make things happen when you really
want to do them so we figured it out
how about country meets boyband when
Florida Georgia line and the Backstreet
Boys team up for a medley national
[Music]
we might be dancing and singing at the
same time who knows anything's possible
[Music]
no matter what happens it happens well a
little something has already happened to
Miranda Lambert we should be fans her
plane to Vegas got diverted so her team
rented a ban her caption rent-a-car set
up the boss
[Music]
Marren Morris has been rehearsing her
duet with Thomas red harder than it
looks I've I've learned like over the
past few award shows how to make it look
larger than life Nancy O'Dell is
presenting again this year her seat is
in the perfect place to catch Tim McGraw
and Faith Hill perform the TV world
premiere of their new song speak to a
girl
[Music]
every night I really just look forward
to hearing or trying to keep up with
speed too
[Music]
you